Speaker 1: There's another new problem for
the Republican Party, which is that college
educated voters are abandoning the party quite
quickly, to a degree that I didn't even realize.
Check out this report from MSNBC about recent
polling.
Speaker 2: Welcome back to the download time.
We've talked a lot here about how the two
political parties are changing.
And now there are new warning signs for the
Republicans in that realignment.
In the first quarter of this year, Gallup
found that Democrats have a nine point edge
in party identification if the largest gap,
Gallup's recorded in a decade.
And now we've seen this before and it hasn't
always stuck.
That said, data from the Pew Research Center
shows that the shift of college educated voters
from red to blue could indeed have long term
consequences.
And here's why.
At the beginning of this century, Republicans
held an 11 point edge among this group of
voters by the time Barack Obama was president.
The figures had flipped and had become a narrow
four point edge for the Democrats.
Then along came President Trump.
And as he was winding down, Democrats had
a whopping 13 point lead among this group
of voters.
Now, here's why this matters, because Republicans
have long counted on the high turnout rates
of college educated suburban voters, especially
during midterm and special elections.
And yet in twenty eighteen sixty four percent
of people with a bachelor's degree went to
the polls.
And watch this.
That compares with fifty two percent of those
with just some college or an associate's degree.
It's thirty nine percent among those high
school or less, and it's only 20 percent for
those without a high school diploma.
All of this could spell trouble for Republicans
if they are losing the most reliable voters
to Democrats.
We actually may have seen that already in
Georgia and in a statewide election in Wisconsin
Speaker 1: when more and more people are getting
college degrees.
How do you win when you have a 13 point deficit
among the college educated voters?
Or to put it another way, college educated
people are more likely to vote and increasingly
more people are going to college and increasingly
those people are going to vote for Democrats.
That's a recipe for disaster for the Republican
Party.
Now, a common sense reaction, if you're the
Republican Party, would be, well, let's figure
out why college educated voters are abandoning
us and let's fix that issue.
But that's not the approach of the Republican
Party.
The Republican approach instead has been let's
trash going to college as liberal nonsense
so maybe fewer people will go.
And meanwhile, let's make it harder to vote
in areas we've identified as being more Democratic
leaning.
And that strategy, it can work in theory,
at least in the short run.
It can also fail.
Arguably, it failed in 2020 in places like
Georgia.
But I don't see how the strategy works long
term.
This is a stunning trend and it's.
Chuck Todd pointed out in that segment, the
Republican Party used to lead among college
educated voters.
Then in the Obama era, Obama was like plus
for among educated, college educated voters.
Now Democrats are a plus 13.
Some of you may be surprised that college
educated voters ever voted for Republicans,
but remember that there was a time when relatively
fewer people went to college.
Those that did made more money.
Therefore, they paid more in taxes and arguably
they would develop some animosity to the party
of higher taxes and they shifted to the right.
Since then, though, the Republican Party,
although it is anti-tax, has become also a
lot of other crazy things antiscience, anti
life, anti common sense.
And the tax thing no longer seems to be the
controlling factor.
You can put it a different way.
Also, the Republican Party has gone so far
off the deep end that they are even starting
to lose the people who want low taxes.
And since Ronald Reagan, as I've told you
many times, the Republican Party has been
creating this environment in which someone
like Trump can win.
They've done it relatively successfully, winning
a bunch of elections.
But when Trump actually came in, he blew everything
up and maybe it was too far.
They now have a policy where policy they have
a party where policy essentially doesn't matter.
It's just rhetoric.
It's owning the Libs.
It's, you know, arguing that you want to bring
guns onto the House floor.
And as a result, they lost the house in twenty
eighteen.
They lost the Senate in twenty twenty.
They lost the White House in twenty twenty.
So they are left with almost nothing.
That is the vacuum into which Fox and Tucker
and Newsmax and these types, Jim Jordan, Marjorie
Taylor Green, they can fill the void with
their outrageous rhetoric, which further radicalizes
the party.
But it's not it's not dealing with policy.
Can they turn it around?
Sure they can.
I mean, you know, I've looked at deeper and
more detailed opinion surveys trying to figure
out what is it that would bring college educated
voters back to the Republican Party if the
country became more religious, would that
do it?
Unclear, unclear.
And remember that the country is becoming
less religious on issues.
The country is also moving left.
You know, abortion being legal in most cases
has the biggest support it's had since Roe
v. Wade.
I mentioned earlier gay marriage being legal
has more support today than at any day in
American history.
Inequality being too high and being bad for
the country is something that more people
today agree with than at any time in the past.
So on the religiosity thing, things aren't
turning back to the right on the issues.
Things aren't turning to the right.
This is why the Republican Party has adopted
a strategy of voter suppression, trying to
steal elections rather than to win them.
And when you see this polling, it does make
sense.
It does matter if you realize we can't seem
to win on issues.
The issues we used to win on are increasingly
going against us.
In that sense, you would try to just win in
other ways, and that's exactly what they're
doing.
We'll take a quick break.
We have much more after this.
Find me.
This is very exciting.
I've not been this excited about a new platform
in a long time.
Find me on Bit Cloud where we have Pakman
coin.
I know it sounds nuts, but it's very interesting.
Go to David Pakman dotcom slash bitcoin.
That's Bitti, Cielo UTI at minimum.
Follow me there.
We're going have some very interesting things
there.
But you're if you're in that space, I think
you'll find the platform really interesting.
Quick break.
Right back after this.